[Music]
all across the world there were many
tribes and ancient civilizations that
were interested in hallucinogenic plants
some used them in spiritual rites
and others saw in them a divine link to
science and knowledge
the good part of their knowledge comes
from the hallucinations induced by
certain plants any credible research
that's blocked typically by government
is probably safer than any other drug
how do we know that this is not a rumor
the cia brought up the world supply of
lsd
there is a whole universe within the
brain which brings us to a dead end
[Music]
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they use psychoactive plants to learn
about the world around them what we did
find seems to be real you could by the
use of drugs reprogram somebody's mind
people underestimate how deep the brain
[Music]
hallucinogenic plants
such as ayahuasca drink and denial blue
lotus
were they the source of knowledge
and technological advancements of our
ancient ancestors
shamans have used hallucinogenic plants
like ayahuasca the blue lotus iboga
peyote and other plants and mushrooms to
seek altered states of mind
and reach a level the priests say opens
the gates of knowledge in dimensions
beyond our realm
and this reminds me of my state as an
actor when i build a character from a
written script i live in a parallel
world like a shaman though in a
different way i'm seeking to tap somehow
into that other dimension
and i enter a different state of
consciousness
i learned many things from acting
first time in my life i went to a
theater audition i messed up badly
i stuttered and i sweated and it was a
scandal
but i don't know why i enjoyed the
experience
so i went back to the director and
offered my services as an assistant and
not an actor just to learn from him and
that is what happened
my experience in theater taught me that
sometimes the truth is beyond what you
can see
but is there really a parallel world of
wisdom and knowledge and are there
people who are able to tap into it
through hallucinogenic plants
my search for that answer led me to a
researcher who studied this topic his
name is jeremy narby hi jeremy hi um
i want to talk a little bit about your
work you have
extensively researched hallucinogenic
plants can you share with me your
hypothesis please i was an
anthropologist um
a young anthropologist 35 years ago in
the peruvian amazon and i was there not
to study hallucinogenic plants but to
study the political economy of the
rainforest
and this
went through trying to understand how
they understood the forest they lived in
and they said that the way to
understand this was to
drink for example ayahuasca which is a
mixture of
hallucinogenic plants
or take concentrated tobacco paste
there are something like eighty 000
species of plants in the amazon
rainforest
european forests have a total of about
300 species so it really is a quite
mind-boggling
some scientists went and they made two
meter by 10 meter plots in the forest
and then they would take different
ashankar people and ask them to walk
through these 20 square meters and
identify plant by plant the plants that
were there and these people had names
for
98 of the plant species
and and they attributed uses to about
half of them so
they really do have
encyclopedic
knowledge about
plants and and what one can do with that
i mean you know how many plants do most
people uh
in switzerland know that they can just
walk out and say i don't know 10 maybe
20.
how did they acquire such immense
botanical knowledge their knowledge
about plants is is recognized by science
and the pharmaceutical industry but they
themselves say that a good part of their
knowledge comes from
the hallucinations induced by certain
plants
with ayahuasca for example they put
whatever plant they find interesting in
the ayahuasca brew and then they drink
it and in their visions
they hope to learn things about other
plants
they use psychoactive plants they use
them intelligently to to learn about the
world around them it's quite a paradox
because they say that the knowledge they
have comes from using the plants how did
they know which plant to use to get this
college it's true that one can see that
paradox especially if one is on the
outside but
on the
inside
what you have is
indigenous amazonian people are just
naturally curious
about their environment interested in
experimenting you know they just have
that sort of basic curiosity
this topic takes me back to the question
of how the pharaohs were able to attain
the science and architecture that
enabled them to build great things like
the pyramids
my research led me to the lotus flower
and that some people say that this plant
is rich in dmt an active hallucinogenic
ingredient and it is the source of
knowledge of the pharaohs or ancient
egyptians
not only the science they used to build
the pyramids many and different sciences
and answers to eternal questions about
life in the universe
according to this theory this knowledge
is kept protected to this day in a
secret chamber in egypt called the hall
of records
carmen bolter director of documentary
series the pyramid code searched for
that hole and may have some answers
it seems that ancient civilizations have
managed to gather exceptional knowledge
some people claim
that this knowledge is actually hidden
in a place called the whole of records
does this place exist
it is a good question and i think edgar
casey the sleeping prophet way back
many many decades ago was one that
talked about it and he also talked about
it being in three different places
now i've researched edgar casey's work
and i think that there you can't take it
all literally so did you figure out
where it is in my time in egypt i spent
a great deal of time
when the plateau closed
in the tunnel system i spent a lot of
time inside the body of the sphinx and
could see that there actually were
blocked
chambers blocked passageways
there's a satellite system called
geoscans
and so when we did the scan
it turned out to be a huge
network
of underground
chambers
not passageways so inside these chambers
there was traces of precious metals gold
precious jewels
no bones no pottery so it wasn't a
civilization it wasn't somewhere they
lived so do you think this is their
famous hole of records
i'm not going to tell you that i know
what this is
that
we can speculate but what we did find
seems to be
real i guess you need a permit to go
inside and see for yourself did you show
the government what you found to get a
permit we made plans we presented it to
the government but of course anything
that goes through to the government they
say yes yes come here show us your
research and then they cancel so do you
think there is a force trying to keep us
away from our ancient knowledge
i would say definitely
it seems that any credible research that
could give us real definitive
information about our ancient past gets
blocked
typically by government
who to believe
some people have the credentials but
they don't ask the right questions
others don't have the credentials
but their questions are good
the question is why are academics
persuaded
not to follow this line of inquiry
who would want to prevent them from
following this path
it seems that western science in the 50s
and the 60s have started researching
this
but
for some reason it all came to an abrupt
end
and the substances were classified
it is said that in 1938 a swiss
scientist named albert hoffman succeeded
in a lab to synthesize a hallucinogenic
drug called lsd
people had experimented with magic
mushrooms and other substances that
altered consciousness
but researching these compounds in a lab
meant science was ready to delve into
this issue
lsd is colorless and essentially free
is uh probably safer than any other drug
this is not a drug there is a voice
until it all came to a stop
but why and who stopped it
lynn picknet is a writer and researcher
who worked extensively on this subject
and i think she can help me
i want to know who would want to stop
research
on such substances
it says it all when you discover that
the cia in the 50s basically brought up
the world's supply of lsd
i mean literally did that and they
wanted to experiment with it this was
because after the second world war
the movement
in military thinking was yes of course
we want to have our traditional weapons
but we want to look more at
psychological warfare
you know how can we for example
um train
assassins um by the
the use of programming their mind like
uh
mk ultra the secret program by the cia
in 1953.
what can you tell us about that it was
terrifying absolutely terrifying it was
based on the real idea
that um
you could theoretically
by the use of drugs and hypnosis
reprogram somebody's mind they used i
think up to 80
institutions such as prisons
um hospitals including some universities
even where they got a few willing
experimentes
but a lot of them weren't willing you
know like in prisons you can imagine and
uh some didn't even know they were being
experimented on which is a whole lot
worse
and they were often force-fed one way or
another um lsd
how do we know that this is not a rumor
and it actually happened in the 70s
actually
most of the mk ultra records were
destroyed but uh the financial records
of antholdia became known they weren't
destroyed and and
looking at them you could see the sheer
extent of them killed you know what they
paid for who they paid
these are professors and
researchers
whose methods are sound and findings are
compelling
but
but the truth
sometimes there are parties interested
in modeling the waters
which brings us to a dead end
i would like to know scientifically what
happens in the brain when someone takes
a hallucinogenic substance
[Music]
is a neuroscientist
and he may have an answer
you did a lot of research on
hallucinogenic plants and drugs and
their relation to human consciousness
when someone takes dmt or lsd
are they connecting with some sort of
universal wisdom or tapping into
cosmic knowledge or anything of that
sort i'm by training i'm a physicist so
i have a very hard time you know
believing that there are things beyond
what we know as the universe itself what
i have to say is that people
underestimate
the the how deep is the brain in the
sense that there is a whole universe
within the brain in its sense so when
people take ayahuasca for example and
they see these wonderful
images in the serpents shingles like the
cosmos they have this instinct okay so
this is so vast that it has to be
outside myself but i think this is wrong
i think that carl sagan once said that
the brain is a very big place in a very
small space it means that there are a
lot of things inside of ourselves that
we aren't usually aware of and it's
exciting for me that would mean we are
all quite similar inside
because we are all human exactly you see
that that's that's a wonderful
conclusion yeah so people there are
differences of course because not
everybody is the same but
at the very core level the secular
experience is very similar across
individuals there is something implicit
in the human being that is tapped when
it's confidence
under the effects of psychology and that
something of course is worth exploring
okay so we are not tapping into
universal wisdom
but are we tapping into other beings
like plants
or other minds
it's not that we read each other minds
like you know waves coming from my brain
to yours but it could happen that still
the bandwidth of the motion that we can
communicate to each other examplify a
lot and that has a little bit of
spiritual meaning by itself it doesn't
have to go against the laws of physics
to be spiritual
[Music]
my journey in the search continues
[Music]
and my journey will continue to move in
different worlds and parallel dimensions
but for sure without hallucinogenic
substances
words to which acting takes me
and the music
[Music]
worlds that may have
answers but for sure in them
there are many more questions
[Music]
[Music]
you